So many things that we thought were
wholesome and innocent really weren't.
There's a lot of push for cohabitation
and making
alcoholism normal part of everyday life.
Family values just being destroyed. A
moral decline in society. We need to get
rid of some stuff. We're just realizing
it's all just garbage. We don't need
this garbage. It's We're not taking it
to heaven. These things are movie. So, I
don't have time in my life to waste on
trash like this.
Smash. It's a Murray. He's so funny. I
just hope this is an encouragement to
you
guys. Anything that you're doing in your
life that's not drawing you towards
Christ and potentially drawing you away
from Christ, it's pointless. It's
useless. Like Solomon said, vanity,
vanity, it's all vanity. That's
pointless. Jesus coming soon. I want to
use that life I have to glorify him so
when he comes he can say well done my
faithful you know don't want to spend
time wasting hours away on stuff like
this that literally not do anything to
bring people closer to Christ in any
Okay.